this is your chance at redemption  Stein about saving our world it's about  saving dears it starts with my character  Scott Lang getting out of jail hank pym  the range that I would steal the  entrance and the teach me how to use it  I'm hope and I and the daughter of hank  pym a no-nonsense powerful woman she  doesn't think that we need you we can do  this ourselves  so he's gonna have to go through  training to become ant-man you should be  able to shrink and grow and I'd I hope  possesses some very impressive skills so  Scotland's come on show me a bunch were  you going for the hand she doesn't dig  him but she feels she has to do what's  right when you're small you have  superhuman strength I'm good good it's  not bad you can become the hero and  protect the world shouldn't be too  difficult